[Applaus]
[Musik]
die u bahn strecke selbst soll 2024
eröffnet werden und das ist jetzt so die
tunnelbohrmaschine bord sich von hier
durch das erdreich bis von einer platz
der republik schließt oder der
vorhandenen u bahn tunnel an da sieht
man oben gar nix dann besser
zurückgezogen und wollte in rund um die
baustelle gestaltet sich schwierig
dass man alleine einen zweistelligen
millionenbetrag dafür ausgeben muss
weltkriegs und umbau feld zu räumen ist
ein beispiel dafür dass das hier nicht
in die infrastruktur mitwachsen
deshalb brauchen wir über und westfalen
straßenbahnwagen und versuchen es vor
allem auch schnell zu machen damit die
kapazität und auch wirklich rollt wird
die leute wollen künftig zur schule
man muss unter den gebäuden durch und
dementsprechend ist klar dass hier auch
große ingenieurs und mineurs kunst nötig
ist natürlich werden wir den nächsten
wochen und monaten uns auch gedanken
über die frage machen wie mit den
kostensteigerungen umgegangen wird
ich gehe davon aus dass der bund einen
hohen anteil übernehmen wird auch das
land wird geld mit anzugeben
eine gefährliche sache weil man eben
durch weiß was man im gestein vorfindet
aber wir hoffen natürlich sind
optimistisch dass ohne unfälle abgeht